Boris Johnson is a prime minister he
finds himself rather boxed in he's
predicated his entire Premiership on one
single aim to leave the EU or knocked
over the thirty-first Deal or No Deal
but how on earth is he going to do it
MPs have blocked his attempts to get a
general election at least try and get a
popular mandate from the people for his
brexit on Halloween
they've also passed a law requiring the
prime minister to seek an extension with
the EU if he fails to secure a deal to
avoid a No Deal exit on October the 31st
cornered but not surrendering he is
sticking to his own plan he will step up
negotiations with Brussels but he's also
clear of one thing he will not ask for
an extension set in him on a collision
course with Parliament and perhaps even
the courts by October the best chance he
has is to try and get a deal but if he
has a plan B to get us out without a
deal on October the 31st he's not
telling his cabinet or any of ours what
it is will he resign will he fight it in
the courts will he ignore the law and
run down the clock will MPs try to
collapse his government these are the
sorts of nuclear options that were
heading for come late October ask the
European Commission in public and
they'll tell you they're still working
to the assumption that the UK leaves at
the end of October but thought some in
private and they are increasingly
convinced that what will really happen
is Boris Johnson coming here to Brussels
in the middle of October for the summit
and asking for an extension now that
would have to be signed off by all 27 of
the other EU leaders and there has been
a suggestion that the Hungarians or the
poles might issue a veto as a favour to
mr. Johnson but in reality that's very
very unlikely in fact the only leader
who might conceive a vetoing extension
is Emmanuel macron of France who is
biblically fed up of brexit talk but I
don't think he'd really want to upset
the euro
applecart that much so the most likely
thing is an extension probably till the
end of January now talks are going on
between UK and European teams but
there's not much talk of concrete
progress instead so far we have no deal
no clarity and no real guarantee but
when Britain will leave the EU for the
moment it's all up in the air as this
threat of a Deal or No Deal continues to
hang over us the one thing we do know is
there's gonna be a lot more uncertainty
and uncertainty is something that
households businesses and indeed the
city don't much like it means weaker
growth the good news is the economy
isn't in recession and moment all
probably isn't it looks like we've got a
bounce-back in the last month and
employment looks relatively strong at
the moment bad news is it's nothing to
write home about this isn't very strong
growth and as we fixate on our domestic
crisis there's all sorts of things going
on around the world whether it's a trade
war whether it's China slowing down
Germany potentially being recession or
indeed a technology revolution that
could change the world that could be a
massive opportunity for Britain if only
we could start talking about something
that wasn't brexit